now let's tell you about the queen who
has had a change of job description for
the first time in at least a decade an
annual report has revised the role of
the monarch to pare down the number of
activities she must fulfill uh suffers
in the newsroom foresters lunchtime so
is this connected what certs happen to
her age and frailty good afternoon nick
well the queen will officially be
slowing down and taking her work-life
balance more seriously what this means
in practice is that her majesty will be
doing less and members of the royal
household including the
prince of wales the future king will be
taking on more responsibilities now the
annual report had removed 13 of the
queen's official duties or
constitutional conventions
as they're called now just to give you a
few examples what we used to have on
there was things like the state opening
of parliament was something that she had
to do of course in may earlier this year
it was her son prince charles who took
over for her she was unwell there is the
appointment of the prime minister uh
meeting heads of state the approval of
official appointments they are just some
of the roles that were designated to the
queen as part of her job description
whereas now her duties have become
somewhat vaguer
it's there she's there to strengthen
unity and national identity amongst uh
the people
at a time of social uh or societal
change her job is to ensure continuity
and stability um she's also there uh now
going to be
rewarding achievement and success even
more
than before for things like more medals
prizes honours and things like garden
parties and also we'll be continuing
with things like support of service so
including but not limited to things like
charity work now we really should not be
surprised the head of state is 96 years
old and has been experiencing several
health issues mobility concerns she
missed some of her jubilee events just
last month now this is all part of the
managed transition uh of the monarchy
formalizing what we have seen the past
few years of the queen essentially
taking a bit more of a back seat nick
all right sava thanks a lot for now